Vous êtes à la réception de
3D Cannabis Center.
Mon nom est Toni Fox,
je suis la propriétaire.
Nous sommes un centre de
marijuana médicale,
avec un centre de cultivation de
10 000 pieds carrés.
Nous venons d'ajouter 8000 pieds à côté.
On va visiter les lieux.
Actuellement, nous sommes un
dispensaire médical,
ce qui veut dire que nous fournissons
les détenteurs de cartes rouges du
Colorado
qui sont éligibles.
Mais à partir du 1er janvier,
nous ouvrirons au public.
Tous les adultes de 21 ans et plus
pourront acheter du cannabis ici.
C'est le stade final?
Vous pourriez dire ça.
Ils doivent encore pousser 3 - 4
semaines,
ils sont à la seconde partie de leur vie,
à la moitié de ce cycle.
Ça prend 2 mois entre le moment
où vous les mettez en pot et la récolte.
Ça va devenir deux à trois fois plus gros
et beaucoup plus lourd.
Vous pouvez le voir.
Le cannabis pousse si vite
que vous pouvez le voir pousser.
Vous consommez vous-même du
cannabis?
Oui. Je suis ce qu'on appelle
une utilisatrice régulière,
parce que je le consomme tous les jours,
plusieurs fois,
selon comment je me sens et mes
besoins.
Parfois je le fume,
parfois je le vaporise,
parfois je le mange,
parfois je le mets sur mes mains sèches
ou mon cou.
Il y a plein de façons de le consommer.
Vous êtes sous l'effet du cannabis
en ce moment ?
Je dirais que oui.
Même si je n'avais pas fumé du cannabis
depuis des jours,
je serais toujours testée positive
au-delà de la limite légale
parce que le THC s'accumule
dans vos cellules graisseuses.
Si vous êtes un utilisateur quotidien,
la limite est de 5 nanogrammes.
Je suis sûr que je serais à 15 ou plus,
même si je n'avais pas fumé
depuis 24 heures.
Vous n'avez pas l'air « stone » pourtant.
Je ne me sens pas « stone ».
Je n'utilise pas le cannabis pour l'être.
Je m'en sers pour apaiser le stress,
les tensions, pour m'endormir,
me détendre.
Aussi pour m'aider à me concentrer,
à être créative.
Je ne l'utilise pas pour être « stone ».
La plupart des gens au Colorado
ne l'utilisent pas pour être « stone ».
Nous serions considérés comme
des utilisateurs quotidiens
et nous l'utilisons de façon efficace
à travers la journée.
La plupart d'entre nous ne sont pas
sous médication de toute sorte,
nous ne consommons pas d'alcool.
C'est juste notre choix
et notre façon de détendre notre corps.
Alors, qu'avons-nous ici?
Chaque jour, nous avons en moyenne
entre 15 et 20 forces disponibles.
Nous avons différentes familles et noms.
Sativa, Indica et High Brix.
Notre prix moyen est de 25 à 35 $
par « tête », taxes incluses.
Comment ça se compare
au marché noir?
C'est à peu près la moitié,
c'est environ 50 à 75 $.
Parlons des différentes façons
de vendre du cannabis.
Les traitements topiques sont géniaux
pour plein de raisons.
La première est qu'il n'y a pas
d'effet psychédélique
quand vous le mettez sur votre peau.
Vous pouvez avoir les bénéfices,
sans l'effet psychédélique.
Il y a des produits comme
les baumes antidouleurs
et les sels de bain.
Ça apaise votre corps de la douleur
ou des tensions.
Ça vous fait vraiment bien dormir.
Il y a aussi des produits alimentaires.
Il y a plein de façons de consommer
du cannabis sans le fumer.
Ce qu'il y a de bien avec un marché
de la marijuana régulé,
c'est que tout est testé.
Vous savez exactement
ce que vous allez avoir à chaque achat.
C'est très facile de doser médicalement,
parce que c'est testé
par une entreprise agréée.
Par exemple, vous avez des suçons,
des boissons gazeuses,
des barres de chocolat.
Elles sont incroyables.
Cette barre contient 300 milligrammes
de cannabis.
C'est vraiment puissant.
Puissant ?
Vous avez besoin d'un très petit morceau
pour en ressentir les effets.
C'est quelque chose que vous devez
garder régulé,
sous clé.
C'est un médicament,
un médicament puissant.
Et c'est aussi un sédatif.
Ça va vous aider à apaiser la douleur,
le stress, à bien dormir,
mais il faut prendre la bonne dose.